[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Cassandra
kicks us off in tcon Arizona Cassandra
what's going on Hi how are you we're
doing well how can we
help so um my husband and I we um
started a rental car business through
turo not sure if you're familiar with
that or not I'm very
familiar yes I can almost guess where
this is all going
yeah so we financed um three vehicles
that are now completely
underwater and um in tuon it's become
pretty saturated so we're not doing as
well as we had started off doing because
we started off doing really great now
since probably January it started to
kind of taper off and then the cars got
into some accidents and then there was
no income from this business so now
we're personally backing it when we have
like no money to back it and so now it's
racking up credit cards and my
husband's um second job bu has is um
having to Fork out the money to pay for
things when in reality that money should
be going towards the credit cards
because he's um when he contracts
workout he has to put on a card and then
gets reimbursed so now we're not being
able to reimburse what he put on the
card because now we have to pay car
payments and insurance
I before before George um digs into the
math here I just need to ask you before
we start talking are you willing to
change your entire posture on this
deal I want out okay is that what you
mean well I want out I know you want out
but the way you're talking about it is
all of these things are happening to
you everything was perfect and then all
these things happen to us and what both
George and I and any of my colleagues
here would say is when you
leverage your soul when you leverage a
business that you can't cover you are at
the whims of the cosmos as to what
happens and so I've never seen somebody
successfully victim their way out of a
problem like this I've only seen people
say well that was dumb we did something
that looked good on the back of a napkin
at a Mexican food restaurant a good one
by the way in Arizona and it didn't work
and
so we're going to have to both get two
jobs or three jobs CU we have three cars
that we can't afford we have five cars
actually and we're going to have to
figure this out and we will never ever
ever ever do this again I've never seen
somebody just be like well then this
happened and this should be going to
this and this it only way out is you
have to change your posture which is we
gambled we put it all on red 17 and it
landed on black 29 we lost it and now we
got to pick up the pieces and go from
here does that makees do you get what
I'm saying no right I get it I'm only
telling you that because I love you but
there's just no way to slump your
shoulders through this yall are going to
have to say we did it and now it's time
to come out swinging the other
way okay you ready so yeah all right lay
it out for what is your current income
if we take turo
away without turo it's about
94,000 okay and What's the total debt
load it's about
110,000 how much of that is the
cars
uh uh 29 on one 29,000 on one 38 on
another and um 20 on another okay and do
you know what all of those are
worth yeah one's worth 19,000 one's
worth 21,000 and one is worth 12 uh yeah
19 20,000 and 12,000 okay do you guys
have any money liquid
cash I have $1,000 in my emergency fund
okay and do you guys have car loans on
your own personal vehicles no those are
paid off we we uh did our debt free
scream a few years back and now here we
are
again not the debt free alum I know I am
completely
ashamed well you're going to get out of
this and one day it'll be a funny story
you tell your kids that's right but
right now there's a lot of pain and fear
as to how we're going to get out of this
ditch um yeah the good news is you guys
have a good income and without turo
which I assume was taking up some time
could you guys pick up more work more
jobs he cannot he's already tapped out
what is he doing he's um an executive
chef and then he's also a contractor for
a company and he travels quite
frequently for that one is that doing
similar Chef Contracting or what it's
different it's a little bit different
it's it's through it's for like he's
working with chefs for that job but so
still in the same field and then what
you what are you doing I'm an
administrative assistant for him at his
executive chef what do you make me I
make about
16,000 I think I'm confused used why
would you work for him when you can go
make double or triple that
elsewhere um I have we have three kids
and no help so I need that flexibility
okay so you're staying at home with the
kids while doing this administrative
work for him part-time yeah yeah that
makes more sense okay I was worried I
was like you need to find a different
job okay yeah all right so if we can
clear 100 Grand here and we can pay off
you know 50 60 a year living off nothing
this becomes a solvable problem to just
pay this all off the other way to
approach it is can we find the
difference you know go to the credit
union and go hey I need a difference for
this loan so that I can get out from
under this bad underwater car situation
then you have a smaller amount of debt
to pay off okay but you're not keeping
these cars anyways and so I like the
idea of getting out as soon as you can
from these underwater vehicles but the
only real way to do it is to come up
with the difference and you need to do
that through savings and cash or you
need to go get a small loan from the
credit unions to cover it okay or if he
travels a lot maybe you sell one of your
paid-off cars and he can Uber to and
from the airport and I know your first
thought is well we can't do that but
here's the deal you're going to have to
either just make peace with you're going
to be paying this off for four or five
years or something has to be different
because the math is not going to change
right so somebody at your local church
will watch your kids for a discounted
rate or you get a job at a local daycare
center where they pay you 32 Grand a
year as a assistant administrator and
your kids go for free or none of this is
what you want but this is what is this
is just choosing reality here or um
y'all make peace with it or you sell his
car and you pay off the difference
between two of these underwaters and now
you're down to just one of the cars and
you see what I'm saying you begin to
knock it out real quick there is not a
path forward without disc
comfort and the question is which
discomfort are you going to choose the
day-to-day discomfort of not doing much
of anything for the next 5 years or a
really uncomfortable right now with the
opportunity to get free in the next 12
to 18 months and then we're going to
save up some money down the road and
never do this again create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life